are you sure it's here we called Gotham
PD he hasn't been seen for over a year
what was that disappeared they said they
thought he might be dead
why come here why Detroit the weather
where's Batman
hey little birdies alone
let's just hope the helis passing
through I'm detective Dick Grayson you
want to talk about what happened can you
help me Rachel that's what she calls
there is something inside nothing Bad's
gonna happen you don't take care of a
kid is complicated you know that better
than anyone I know how healing it must
be doing what Bruce did for you and you
lost your parents what happened between
you and Bruce I guess we had different
ideas and how to do the job we're gonna
go see some old friends of mine tada
call me what do you want from me
I've been looking for you there are
people out there trying to hurt you
I feel danger
there you are dear
what are you doing we almost make
sacrifices child
[Music]
[Music]
does never go away what the feeling you
got left behind
[Music]
you